andy asks should anger always be
subordinate to reason so this is where
we get into the virtues and vices and
and the answer for aristotle
is yes but that doesn't mean that you
don't get angry as if like reason
you know is like a blocker for for
anger um it does have to remain you
could say integrated with reason in
order to be virtuous so
to have the virtue and this again goes
to andy's question
to have the virtue is not just to
act in accordance with reason and with
prudence practical wisdom which we're
going to talk about much more in a
couple weeks
it also means to behave as
like he says
to be just or to be temperate means to
behave in the way that the just or the
temperate person does it's like taking
on a certain kind of style and i think
we can apply this to anger too you know
we we probably need decent role models
to help us
see what being angry and responding
appropriately looks like and if we have
the wrong role models if we have you
know fly off the handle people in our
lives as our parents or our teachers or
you know uh bosses or whoever we
probably pick up those
bad
criteria for how to be angry or when to
be angry or any any of those sorts of
things so we want to um
you know remind ourselves of that now he
does also talk about another way in
which some people are virtuous with
respect to anger
and he says that the person is calm
ataraxos literally undisturbed
and they're not driven by the emotion
but they behave as reason ordains which
goes you know to andy's question once
again
sometimes you can behave like you're
angry you can impose retribution
but you do so not because you're
actually motivated by the emotion you're
actually
saying ah it's not a good good idea for
me to let them get away with this and i
should say something i should do
something
andy says does aristotle believe there's
no decision procedure aristotle believes
there's no decision procedure for any of
the virtues that's part and that's part
of virtue ethics right
any virtue ethics there will not be a
decision procedure as there is for
utilitarianism or conscientionology
instead they'll be a much more
sophisticated
and character-driven sort of set of
considerations that then we have to
apply
andy goes on and says what must be done
in a particular instance depends on the
situation one's in so for example
there's no never lie claim as some
instances may call for lying we would
deliberate to the mean and then act yeah
i mean aristotle doesn't actually worry
that much about truth and lies
in this except when it comes to as we're
going to look at in several weeks truth
and lying about oneself one's qualities
one's characteristics and things like
that
um but yeah it's going to be context
dependent so there might be some
situations in which you know you
probably should never get angry you know
if you're
uh in charge of you know all these
buttons controlling nuclear weapons and
you know that there's a tendency for you
to like you know launch them if you
don't get angry right uh but in most
cases aristotle's gonna say
it's like you know figuring out where's
the mean
um
and it could vary from situation to
situation you know that's why it's so
important to pay attention to all these
intensifiers of anger or
dynamics in which we we do get angry
and you know we want to keep in mind
if we're lucky enough to have them the
role models
that we have of people who are
um virtuous with respect to their
response of anger so
after this goes to that question does
anger have an object yes it has a very
general object
apparent retribution retribution
now timorias is coming from the word for
honor or social status temurias is sort
of like a restoration of the social
status that has been taken
from one that um was damaged that was
lowered in some respect you you set
things right that you know you uh
rectify things
the phenomena
means apparent or
imagined this is very very important so
people are
looking when they're angry for something
that we could translate as
public retribution or
imaginary retribution or apparent
retribution kind of in the middle
something that they can take as being
retribution even if the other person
isn't so you might have somebody who you
know tries to insult somebody else and
they're not really insulted by it and
they do that because they're angry with
the person and the other person is like
whatever dude you know i don't care what
you think and um
that can be retribution for the first
person who's like i got you man i really
zinged you so you know
it really uh matters this uh
you could say subjectivity that's
involved there
this is
david says i feel like the intensifiers
can be summarized as getting angry in
front of anyone
um
i wouldn't try to
summarize them i would say each of them
is distinct same thing with the dynamics
the risk of summarizing is that things
become so generic that we lose the
specificity
see
does aristotle believe anger has to have
an object or subject be caused by
something or does he see it as a
property of all rational human beings
and therefore a trait that has to be
trained
yes both
we're all susceptible to anger unless
unless we're really really weird
biologically right
um
and
some people feel it less we're going to
talk about that in in just a bit
aristotle kind of thinks that's a vice
anger always does have some sort of
object it's directed but it can shift
directions right you can start up being
angry at one person
and then get angry at another person
for defending that first person it's
pretty um malleable that way
and it is caused we're going to get into
that as soon as we talk about the
definitions of anger
um george has a question about how do
you get yourself out of anger and i'm
going to address that in just a little
bit
um
[Music]
when we get to talking about
remedies which aristotle doesn't really
provide now aristotle
does not give us
as like say the stoics do or even the
epicureans do or later platonus do he
doesn't give us
practical exercises
for doing this he also doesn't give us
things like epictetus saying have this
this statement ready at hand
um and that's kind of a a lack within
aristotle's
ethical
approach
but i don't think that means that we
can't take what aristotle does tell us
and
use that you know build off of that
develop that into exercises and so let
me give you an example of how we
we might be able to do that
each of these rights
that we talked about with the virtuous
mean
we can take a pause which is very very
helpful when it comes to anger
counting to 10 really does help so long
as during the time that you're counting
to 10 you're not like
one i'm so angry two i'm so angry three
i can't believe that son of a [ __ ] four
you know
so long as you're actually like not
concentrating on your anger that'll help
and then you can say to yourself
am i angry with the right person
yes or no
and you you have to be careful with
yourself not to buy into your own
excuses right
but it's possible to do maybe you also
need somebody else to help you out with
that to like be next to you saying
hey man you're screwing up right
am i angry over the right things or
should i are these the sort of things i
shouldn't be angry about and if i am
angry over them can i figure out why i'm
so angry about this trivial stuff what's
going on here what what's happening
that's that's the thing you can do
um
am i expressing my anger in the right
way you know do i need to play some
limits on how i'm expressing my anger
um
how long should i be angry about this
you know what what else can i do to try
to replace this anger with some other
kind of
affectivity or emotion
we can also be on guard against
something that aristotle does tell us
about
aristotle says that anger
syllogizes which means that it involves
reasoning processes you know that that
whole complicated definition
i have been slighted by that jackass
over there who didn't have any good
reason to do it
and it's affecting me and now it made me
upset i feel pain because of that
sliding i should retaliate against that
person
and the retaliation should be something
that's you know really clear for me
phenomena
there's a reasoning process there and
aristotle says that we can
try to avoid being led down these paths
anger is like a hasty servant who
listens to half of what's being said and
then goes off and you know rushes to
complete the instructions that it
misheard
we can look at our own tenancy that
george how do you shake yourself out of
this prism of anger you can say to
yourself
i am probably being stupid right now
and i need to take it take a step back
and look carefully at how i'm
thinking about these these matters right
i need to see how i'm syllagizing or how
my how my anger is running the show how
it seduced
practical
rationality
um
and we could bring in other exercises
from other other people as well
let's actually take allison's first if
you don't like confrontation
you're probably going to avoid getting
angry so would aristotle see that as a
lack of courage so it's not about
courage here it's about
it's about anger and angers management
courage and and mildness are two
different virtues
and if you don't like confrontation um
that doesn't mean that you're not
necessarily getting angry people get
angry
and stew and don't express it and then
find some other way to vent that anger
because they don't like confrontation
you know there are rage rooms that you
can purchase time in where you go in and
smash stuff up aristotle will probably
say
not really a great idea and then there's
also expressing your anger you know
passive aggressively which aristotle
doesn't talk about but i think is
another vicious
disposition that that's possible
um and so you know
a
confrontation avoidance from an
aristotelian perspective
could in fact lead
eventually down the line to developing a
vicious disposition
of of you know being
passive of
being um
as he says slavish or spiritless when it
comes to anger this unfortunately
happens to a lot of people
in family situations where like only the
dad gets to be angry and the kids don't
get to be angry right
and they get beat if if they display
anger is as a form of defiance right um
that can really
screw things up for for them
psychologically and then uh ethically as
well
um being given all sorts of bad examples
be like this other person over here who
put up with everything and never
retaliated
from an aristotelian perspective that
kind of saintly patience is actually
bad for us
so this is where aristotle is going to
differ from like i said some some of the
later christian authors from the stoics
but he's going to be in line with you
know plato and the epicureans and some
other christian authors
christian authors now george says how is
it possible to shake yourself out of
that prism of anger given that you
genuinely believe other people deserve
your retribution so
broader question about
how if you recognize that you
are vicious
how do you work to get yourself away
from that viciousness and start moving
yourself towards
if not virtue at least self-control
right acting like the virtuous person
even though it's tough for you to do it
aristotle doesn't give you an answer to
that this is where we have to go beyond
the aristotelian texts aristotle even
seems to
tell us that the vicious person
doesn't really realize they're vicious i
don't think this tracks with our
experience i think we have plenty
of experience of not just being not not
just having a lack or loss of
self-control what we call lacrossia
but realizing that we're messed up
you know that we have a vicious
disposition when it comes to anger like
we can realize
holy crap i really want revenge against
these people and this seems kind of out
of proportion but this is the way i feel
and this is the way i am and oh it sucks
right and then then there's things we
can do we can start um working on anger
management now aristotle
uh malcolm has a good question here to
go out on i'm curious why the nicki
mccain tends to be privileged for the ud
and ethics so
um
couple good reasons one is
the nico mccain ethics is is longer it's
got more material
it's often viewed and this is a
contested issue in aristotle scholarship
as more mature than the eudaimian ethics
sometimes the eudaimian ethics is viewed
as like aristotle was still under the
influence of plato before he fully came
into his own
and the other thing is too the the nico
mccann ethics became
the ethics that medieval aristotelians
were using
and the udamian ethics only kind of
comes on the scene
later on um
but it is it is a good point i mean the
udain the nick of mccain ethics it's
great
it's much better when we supplement it
with the udamian ethics
you